we're making a big mistake i think
because we all we ever talk about is the
transgender thing that's all
conservatives are focused on right now
and
for good reason because it's it's the
most radical social transformation at
least on the surface that we have ever
seen in this country not just the idea
that we need to change certain behaviors
but the claim that there's no difference
between men and women the fundamental
distinction in human nature
and the men can really be women we've
got to mutilate people and chop them up
and get rid of the girls room and let
husky hank you know walk in to the
public swimming pool and get naked in
front of your daughter it's obviously so
radical and insane this is why this is
the dominant issue for conservatives to
be talking about and for the libs to be
pushing for that matter
i feel though that conservatives are
making a huge mistake in how we fight
on this issue
i just discussed this at the national
conservatism conference down in miami
we know that the conservative strategy
is failing we know that despite all of
our bluster and talk and obsession about
transgenderism it's not really working
maybe we win a governorship in virginia
maybe we push back a little bit in
florida but if you just look at the
progression of the law transgenderism is
completely winning it's being shrined in
law by the supreme court by the
legislatures
in schools in corporations everywhere
okay conservatives have completely lost
on this issue and i think the reason for
that is because conservatives are making
a very shallow argument the conservative
argument right now against
transgenderism is
is
science says that men and women are
different
that's the argument the the lib argument
for transgenderism is there's biological
sex and there's gender expression and
those two things are different and they
can be in contradiction with one another
okay and it's a little more complicated
because sometimes the libs will say that
there's such a thing as a biologically
female
phallus or a biologically male uterus
and that's obviously very confusing but
when when the libs are being their most
coherent they say transgenderism rests
on a distinction between sex and gender
expression
and the conservative response
is
no gender expression is not real it's
only sex it's only biology it's only x
chromosomes and
x y chromosomes and genitals and that's
all it is that's how you know sex
and i thought
no that is that actually isn't true
obviously there's such a thing as gender
expression
gender expression is
gender expression is to sex sort of like
what the soul is to the body
right it's the metaphysical aspect of
the physical thing the body's physical
the sex is physical the gender
expression the soul are metaphysical
obviously we know this is true because
men and women behave somewhat
differently in different cultures
obviously we know this is true because
men can be effeminate
obviously we know this is true because
women can be masculine of course there
can be one's expression of sex and
gender
can be
at odds or a little little separated
from one's physical sex so what's the
answer to this i don't think the answer
is to just deny it because when you deny
it then you fall into the same
soul-denying scientism that the the libs
used to get us into this mess in the
first place
i think the way that you
have to address this is by granting yes
of course there's such a thing as gender
expression
yeah of course
and you have a duty
to bring your gender expression in line
with your sex yeah of course these two
things are distinct the symbol and the
symbolize the body and the spirit sure
you have a duty to bring them into
alignment with one another
this word duty used to be so central to
the conservative
view of the world i mean this is what
edmund burke talked about edinburgh and
the reflections on the revolution of
france he talked about that generous
loyalty to rank and sex that proud
submission that dignified obedience that
found even in servitude itself the
spirit of an exalted freedom not just
our rights and our entitlement and our
physical bodies i mean we're talking
like the leftist materialists when we
talk that way no duty
boys
are supposed to act like boys they're
not supposed to act like girls and girls
are supposed to act like girls they're
not supposed to act like boys you have a
duty to fulfill a role in society
because we're not free-floating atoms we
live in a society
okay we live in a political community
and we find our place in that political
community not primarily by demanding a
bunch of rights and entitlements but
through
duty and recognizing our roles and for
fulfilling those roles
which we can perceive
in the political community and from the
transcendent moral order
that's what it's about
to to quote don that the actual
conservative response on this should not
be well actually science says so there
are two x chromosomes or whatever it
should be the don corleone response when
he's talking to johnny fontaine johnny
fontaine says godfather i don't know
what to do i don't can't get out of my
car he says
who are you talking about you can act
like a man
what's the matter with you there is a
video that has gone viral it's being
reported by reuters i have instructed my
editors to blur this video it's a video
of a 10 year old drag kid
who was just the headliner of new york's
fashion week and the video is everywhere
and it's being reported on by big news
organizations without blurring his face
i don't care it's child abuse what this
this kid's guardians are doing to him is
child abuse what the media are doing to
him is child abuse and so
i at least and i encourage other
conservatives to follow suit i'm gonna
i'm gonna blur this kid's face he goes
by noella mcmahor
uh he's a a ten-year-old who has been
convinced to become a transgender model
and activist here's what he had to say
about his starring role at new york's
fashion week
what is normal what is normal it's 2022.
no one knows what normal is at this
point
[Music]
she's believed to be the youngest
transgender model to walk ever cool to
have that title and
it shows that i actually am like
showing other showing other people and
kids that being transgender isn't bad
through her social media she wants
people to know trans kids are not
different from other kids
we want to make sure that um there it is
we're supporting her dreams and the fact
that
to
be an activist and be visible for other
trans kids
we know it's just so important in a
world that especially right now in our
current political climate that has so
many things that are working against her
kids like her okay for those who
couldn't watch that consider yourselves
lucky uh that last little bit there is
in what looks like times square and it's
d's
whatever the the boy's name is noella is
his fake name noella's parents
quote unquote and noella's parents are
these kind of
androgynous looking people one of whom
calls him herself d but d has some
facial hair and looks kind of like a man
but i think he's actually a woman and
then this other eunuch sort of looking
person who
i think is also a woman but also is
dressing up like a boy and i remember
reading a story about this the poor
little boy's
uh father who now has no role in his
life and was was booted out of the
family life and uh
said he has no say now over all this
crazy transgender stuff
obviously
this is from the the weird lesbian
transgender whatever uh
parents you know guardians who are
abusing this child they should have no
right to even see this child they should
be in prison that this the sort of
things that they're doing to themselves
into this child should be illegal and
and all of that was true
all this stuff was illegal extremely
stigmatized until very very recently
the child certainly would have been
taken away by child protective services
even ten years ago
if if not even more recently
but now we live in this upside down
world where
extremely sexually confused mentally ill
people are allowed to to abuse
little children and parade a little boy
around in dresses like a sexual object
at the age of 10 at a new york fashion
show and we're not only are we not
allowed to criticize that very likely
this segment will be taken down or media
matters will clip it or there will be
but whatever who cares i mean it's just
it is what it is
not only are we not allowed to criticize
it we have to celebrate it
and it just leads to this question
that is very hard for conservatives to
consider
are we the baddies
are we the baddies because i look around
at all sorts of terrible regimes around
the world
and
regimes which in many ways do many worse
things than the united states
china
russia all these you know regimes that
do bad stuff
i don't think those regimes
trot 10 year old boys in in little
skirts down the runway
for the seal-clapping applause of of
sexual degenerates and perverts in in
new york city in the public square and
encourage all of this stuff
that's not that that sort of thing isn't
celebrated there
are we the baddies
we didn't i don't think we used to be
the baddies
i think this is kind of a recent thing
but it's a really big deal and even
beyond the transgender question the fact
that you've now got the president of the
united states sicking his own his
federal law enforcement which is acting
like his kind of personal police force
to it to raid the home of his former of
his predecessor and current chief
political rival that's pretty batty
stuff that's what they do in really
batty banana republic regimes the fact
that the president is now hiring 87 000
new irs agents some of whom he's going
to arm to go down and shake you down for
more money than they're already taking
that doesn't seem like a good sign
especially when he's calling you
fascists and saying your very existence
is a threat to the country that seems
that seems kind of dangerous and scary
the fact that we we allow
the
and encourage at the highest levels of
government we encourage a roving gangs
of criminals to burn the country down
for eight months at a time in a kind of
ecstatic religious celebration of of a
career criminal who was killed because
he took a fatal drug
amount of illegal drugs and resisted
arrest while committing a crime
does that make a lot of sense i don't
know i just kind of fear that we're
becoming the baddies
and the democrats are actively
encouraging us to be the baddies and
they're cheering it on and threatening
to line us all up against the wall at
their call to arms
and what are the conservatives doing
we're saying well
you know i can't force my morality on on
anybody
you know i don't listen listen i don't
want to i don't want to force my
religious views on anybody okay i might
not support
ten-year-old boys being sexually abused
by
by their uh lesbian eunuch guardians and
being trotted out for the sexual
pleasure of depraved people in new york
city i might not support it okay
all right but i will fight to the death
to defend your right to do it no what
are you talking about what do you no no
yeah please impose your morality
you have to
you have to please impose your religious
views that your your crazy extreme
religious view that we shouldn't
sexualize 10 year olds and march them
down the runway and have them dancing
around at bars in the country
for dollar bills which has happened
multiple times now on video
please impose your crazy morality that
says that uh children should be allowed
to be children and raised with their
mother and father and not not have their
genitals chopped off please i support it
if that's theocracy then sign me up baby
call me the holy roman emperor okay
right now text knolls to 989898
the biden administration has recently
announced its plan to hire 87 000 new
irs agents in 2023 many of whom will be
bearing arms as they shake you down for
your money you need to secure your
savings in a tax sheltered account now
and birch gold can help you do just that
birch gold group helps you hold gold and
silver in a tax sheltered retirement
account to protect you from big
government trying to take all your
wealth plus throughout history gold has
always been your best hedge against
inflation a diversified savings can
protect you from downturns in the market
if you have a 401k or ira that is
underperforming just text knowles canada
w l e s to 98 98 98 and you can convert
that into an ira in precious metals
right now birch gold group has an a plus
rating with a better business bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers text
knolls to 98 98 98 and birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into gold tax free take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
protect your hard-earned money get your
free info kit by texting knolls to 98
98.98 now i'm so glad you liked that
clip now
you got to ring that bell subscribe get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you